There may be no stage in life that's more maligned than adolescence. When people think of teenagers, the words that may come to mind include moody, impulsive, risk-taking, and self-centered. In the movies, on TV and in our imaginations, teenagers drive too fast, they experiment with drugs and alcohol, and they cave to peer pressure to take other unwise risks. Looking back, many of us probably remember doing a few of those things ourselves when we were teens. And teenage brains, so the stereotype goes, are driving these actions.
人生中可能没有哪个阶段比青春期更受诟病。当人们想到青少年时，脑海中浮现的词汇可能包括喜怒无常、冲动、爱冒险和以自我为中心。在电影、电视和我们的想象中，青少年开车太快，尝试毒品和酒精，并屈服于同伴压力去冒其他不明智的风险。回首往事，我们许多人可能还记得自己十几岁时也做过其中的一些事情。而刻板印象认为，正是青少年的大脑在驱动这些行为。
These brains just haven't developed enough for young people to make good decisions. But researchers are increasingly finding that this negative view of the adolescent brain is inaccurate and incomplete. Yes, teenagers are still a work in progress, but the brain changes that mark adolescents make it a time of great opportunity and growth as well as risk. So what is happening in the teenage brain? Do adolescents take more risks than other age groups and is that risk taking always bad? Who has more influence over teens' behavior, their parents or their peers? Are teens really more self-centered than adults? And how might social media and other technology use be changing teens' behavior and development?
这些大脑还没有发育到足以让年轻人做出正确决定的程度。但研究人员越来越多地发现，这种对青少年大脑的负面看法是不准确且不完整的。是的，青少年仍处于成长过程中，但标志着青春期的大脑变化使其成为一个充满机遇和成长以及风险的时期。那么青少年大脑中到底发生了什么？青少年比其他年龄段的人承担更多的风险吗？这种冒险行为总是坏事吗？谁对青少年的行为影响更大，是他们的父母还是同伴？青少年真的比成年人更以自我为中心吗？社交媒体和其他技术的使用又如何改变青少年的行为和发展？
Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Eva Telzer, an associate professor of psychology and neuroscience at the University of North Carolina Chapel Hill. She studies teens' brain development and behavior with a focus on risk-taking, family and peer relationships, prosocial behavior, and long-term psychological well-being. She's also interested in how social media and technology are affecting teens' brain development.
欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是北卡罗来纳大学教堂山分校心理学和神经科学副教授伊娃·泰尔泽博士。她研究青少年的大脑发育和行为，重点关注冒险、家庭和同伴关系、亲社会行为以及长期的心理健康。她还对社交媒体和技术如何影响青少年的大脑发育感兴趣。
and she is the co-director of the Winston National Center on Technology Use, Brain, and Psychological Development. She has received many awards for her work, including APA's Boyd-McCandless Award for Early Career Contributions to Developmental Psychology, and the Association's Distinguished Scientific Award for Early Career Contributions to Psychology. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Telzer. Thank you so much for having me. Let's start with a definition so that we're on the same page in terms of what age group we're talking about. In your research, how do you define adolescence? Is it just the teenage years from 13 to 19, or does it encompass a broader range?
她同时担任温斯顿国家技术使用、大脑和心理发展中心联席主任。她因其工作获得了许多奖项，包括美国心理学会颁发的博伊德-麦坎德莱斯早期职业发展心理学贡献奖，以及该协会颁发的杰出科学早期职业心理学贡献奖。感谢您今天加入我们，泰尔泽博士。非常感谢您的邀请。让我们从定义开始，以便我们对所讨论的年龄段达成共识。在您的研究中，您如何定义青春期？它仅仅是13到19岁的青少年时期，还是涵盖了更广泛的范围？
So defining adolescence is quite complicated. It is not necessarily defined by age. It's not necessarily defined by other markers, such as the onset and offset of puberty. And so when we study adolescents, we often are following youth across time to look at change. We typically start in middle school, so six and seventh graders in the United States, for example, and following them through the end of high school. So 12th grade in the United States, sometimes our research starts a little bit younger and sometimes goes a little bit older. But for the most part, we're studying adolescents from approximately sixth grade to 12th grade. So one of the most common negative stereotypes about teens is that they take a lot of unnecessary and unwise risks.
定义青春期非常复杂。它不一定由年龄定义。它也不一定由其他标志定义，例如青春期的开始和结束。因此，当我们研究青少年时，我们通常会随着时间的推移跟踪年轻人以观察变化。我们通常从初中开始，例如美国的六年级和七年级学生，并跟踪他们直到高中结束。也就是美国的12年级，有时我们的研究开始得早一点，有时结束得晚一点。但大多数情况下，我们研究的是大约六年级到12年级的青少年。所以关于青少年最常见的负面刻板印象之一是他们承担了许多不必要和不明智的风险。
that this risk-taking tendency is wired into their brains. How accurate is that? Are teens more prone to take risks compared with adults and even younger children? Yeah, so there's a fair amount of research looking at risk-taking behaviors and how this might change across development. So following youth, starting in childhood through adolescence to adulthood, and even doing this work across nationally, researchers have found what looks like an inverted U-shaped pattern with adolescents showing the highest levels of risk-taking behaviors. So this ranges from behaviors that might be construed as negative, like, substance use behaviors, but also less risky behaviors.
这种冒险倾向是植入他们大脑的。这有多准确？与成年人甚至更小的孩子相比，青少年是否更容易冒险？是的，有相当多的研究关注冒险行为以及这在整个发展过程中如何变化。因此，通过跟踪年轻人，从童年到青春期再到成年，甚至在全国范围内进行这项工作，研究人员发现了一种看起来像倒U型的模式，青少年表现出最高水平的冒险行为。这范围从可能被解释为负面的行为，如物质使用行为，但也包括风险较低的行为。
So on an experimental task, for example, where you can manipulate rewards that they might receive, but a risk of not getting that reward, we can see that adolescents more so than children and more so than adults choose to take the risk in order to receive that reward. And this is thought to be driven by sensation-seeking and reward-seeking behaviors that are substantiated in the brain. So there's quite a bit of research out there showing that an area of the brain called the ventral striatum, which codes for reward value, is more activated in adolescence when they receive rewards and when they take risks, then this brain region is activated in children or adults. So it is true based on the empirical research out there that adolescents are more likely to
例如，在实验任务中，你可以操纵他们可能获得的奖励，但存在得不到该奖励的风险，我们可以看到，青少年比儿童和成年人更倾向于冒险以获得该奖励。这被认为是由大脑中证实的寻求刺激和寻求奖励的行为所驱动的。因此，有相当多的研究表明，大脑中一个称为腹侧纹状体的区域（负责编码奖励价值）在青少年获得奖励和冒险时比在儿童或成年人中更活跃。因此，根据现有的实证研究，青少年更有可能
take risks and that there is evidence from the brain that supports why this might be happening. So it's perhaps driven by this tendency to seek out rewards. But the widely held stereotype that this is very negative and drives only negative behavior, like teens recklessly driving or jumping off a bridge or doing other more negative risks may be overstated because teens are engaging in so many positive risks that are sometimes overlooked in the media as well as parents worried about what teens might be doing with their peers, for example. And so there's lots of risks that might be construed as more positive. So, for example, if you're in a class and the teacher raises a question, some teens may feel very nervous about raising their hand and answering the question. But you might do so. You might raise your hand and answer the question, even if you're kind of afraid of your peers thinking poorly of you or not getting the answer right.
承担风险，并且有来自大脑的证据支持为什么会发生这种情况。所以这可能是由这种寻求奖励的倾向所驱动的。但那种认为这是非常负面且只会导致负面行为（如青少年鲁莽驾驶、跳桥或进行其他更负面的冒险）的广泛刻板印象可能被夸大了，因为青少年正在参与许多积极的风险，这些风险有时在媒体中被忽视，父母也担心青少年可能与同伴一起做什么。因此，有很多风险可能被解释为更积极的。例如，如果你在课堂上，老师提出了一个问题，一些青少年可能会因为举手回答问题而感到非常紧张。但你可能会这样做。你可能会举手回答问题，即使你有点害怕同伴看不起你或者答不对。
And so that's just one example of a positive risk. There's also what we define as a pro-social risk. So this is going out of your way, potentially risking social status or other types of risks that may come with some backlash in order to help somebody else. So as an example, there might be a kid getting bullied in school. And so a pro-social risk would be standing up to the bully and helping out that kid who's being bullied. And so there is this potentially huge risk that the bully is going to backlash at you or that your social status. You may be viewed more negatively by some of the cool kids in school, but the potential positive of this is helping out that kid who might be getting bullied. So you mentioned an area of the brain that's activated, right, which is why some teens may be taking risk.
这只是积极风险的一个例子。还有我们定义的亲社会风险。这就是为了帮助别人而付出努力，可能冒着社会地位或其他可能带来一些反弹的风险。举个例子，学校里可能有孩子被欺负。那么亲社会风险就是站出来对抗欺凌者，帮助那个被欺负的孩子。因此，存在这种巨大的潜在风险，即欺凌者会反击你，或者你的社会地位会受到影响。你可能会被学校里的一些酷孩子看得更负面，但这样做的潜在积极意义是帮助那个可能被欺负的孩子。所以你提到了大脑中被激活的一个区域，对吧，这就是为什么一些青少年可能会冒险。
Does the same thing happen in adults? And how is it that adults can regulate that? So there is heightened ventral stride in activation in adults, too, when they engage in risks and receive rewards. it's just not as high as it is in adolescent. So there's thought to be less of this reward drive in adults. There's what is now thought to be a relatively simplified view of the development of reward seeking and risk taking behavior, which is not necessarily robustly supported in the research, which I think you're alluding to, which is this idea of regulation where adults are better regulated, have a more developed prefrontal cortex, and therefore they can
成年人也会发生同样的情况吗？成年人又是如何调节这种行为的呢？是的，成年人在参与冒险和获得奖励时，腹侧纹状体的激活程度也会升高，只是没有青少年那么高。因此，人们认为成年人的这种奖励驱动力较小。现在人们认为对寻求奖励和冒险行为的发展有一种相对简化的看法，这在研究中并不一定得到强有力的支持，我想你指的就是这种调节观念，即成年人调节能力更好，拥有更发达的前额叶皮层，因此他们可以
can downregulate that ventral striatim response. But that's not necessarily the full story here. Adolescents actually are very good at regulating their behavior. They have not a broken brain or undeveloped prefrontal cortex, but a regulatory system that's very flexible and can be engaged to meet their motivational goals. And so it's not that they can't regulate their behavior. It's just that sometimes their goal is not to regulate their behavior because the reward of one behavior just may be much more highly valued than the reward of regulating that behavior. And so they choose to engage in it. It's not that they are incapable of not stopping themselves from engaging in it.
下调那种腹侧纹状体的反应。但这并不一定是故事的全部。青少年实际上非常擅长调节自己的行为。他们的大脑并没有受损，前额叶皮层也没有发育不全，而是一个非常灵活的调节系统，可以被调动以满足他们的动机目标。所以并不是他们不能调节自己的行为。只是有时他们的目标不是调节自己的行为，因为某种行为的奖励可能比调节该行为的奖励价值高得多。所以他们选择参与其中。并不是他们没有能力阻止自己参与其中。
There's an idea that the teenagers are egged on by their peers to take risks and that their parents don't have a whole lot of influence over them at this point in life. What have you found in your research, do parents, or peers have more influence when it comes to teens risk taking? Yeah, so there is absolutely this stereotype out there that peers are going to drive adolescents to engage in largely negative behaviors, and that parents have less of a role in affecting their teens' decision-making. And what's remarkable is that there's really been no research to support this, and
有一种观点认为，青少年在同伴的怂恿下冒险，而父母在人生的这个阶段对他们没有太大的影响力。您在研究中发现了什么，在青少年冒险方面，父母还是同伴的影响力更大？是的，确实存在这种刻板印象，即同伴会驱使青少年参与主要是负面的行为，而父母在影响青少年决策方面的作用较小。令人瞩目的是，实际上没有任何研究支持这一点，而且
not a lot of research out there has even been done to ask this. very question. And so we have completed several studies now in my lab to look at the relative role of parent and peer influence on adolescents risk-taking behaviors, as well as they're more positive types of behaviors like pro-social behaviors or healthy behaviors. And what we have found is across multiple studies now, either parents and peers have a similar influence on adolescence decision-making or parents actually outweigh that of their peers. In one study, for example, adolescents had the decision to take a risk or not in the presence of conflicting information from their parent and their peer. So their parent may have said, take the risk, and their peer
也没有多少研究去问这个问题。因此，我的实验室现在已经完成了几项研究，以观察父母和同伴对青少年冒险行为以及他们更积极的行为（如亲社会行为或健康行为）的相对影响。我们通过多项研究发现，父母和同伴对青少年决策的影响相似，或者父母的影响实际上超过了同伴。例如，在一项研究中，青少年在面对来自父母和同伴的相互冲突的信息时，必须决定是否冒险。所以他们的父母可能说，去冒险，而他们的同伴
may have said, no, play it safe, and vice versa. And what we find is that teens are more likely to go along with what their parent says than with what their peer says in this risk-taking context. In other studies, for example, looking at their risk attitudes and their pro-social attitudes, we find that teens go along with their parents' attitudes and their peers' attitudes at about a 50-50 level. So they're just as likely to follow what their parents' attitudes are as they are to follow what their peers' attitudes are. And what's actually quite striking is that they stick with their own attitudes more often than they go along with what their parents or their peers think.
可能说，不，安全第一，反之亦然。我们发现，在这种冒险背景下，青少年更有可能听从父母的话，而不是同伴的话。在其他研究中，例如观察他们的风险态度和亲社会态度，我们发现青少年在50%的情况下听从父母的态度，在50%的情况下听从同伴的态度。所以他们听从父母态度的可能性和听从同伴态度的可能性是一样的。而且实际上非常引人注目的是，他们坚持自己态度的频率比听从父母或同伴想法的频率更高。
And so rather than being like overly susceptible to what other people think in their social environment, especially their peers, adolescents are actually kind of sticking to their guns more often than they are to follow what their peers think or even what their parents think. And we think that this is quite remarkable compared to the overall stereotype that teens are overly susceptible to others. And actually, teens kind of are independent thinkers and stick with what they think are positive and negative behaviors more so than they are to go along with others. You've found that risk taking can be adaptive in development. What do you mean by that? How does risk taking essentially help young people grow and develop? Sure. So there's lots of different
因此，青少年并没有过度受社会环境中其他人（尤其是同伴）想法的影响，实际上他们比听从同伴甚至父母的想法更倾向于坚持自己的立场。我们认为，与青少年容易受他人影响的总体刻板印象相比，这一点非常了不起。实际上，青少年更像是独立的思考者，他们坚持自己认为积极和消极的行为，而不是随波逐流。您发现冒险在发展中可以是适应性的。您是什么意思？冒险如何从本质上帮助年轻人成长和发展？当然。所以有很多不同的
ways that risk taking can be adaptive. One is that just from an evolutionary perspective, going out, learning from your environment, engaging in kind of flexible behaviors, trial and error helps adolescents to learn and develop and explore who they are and what matters to them. It allows them to make new friends to get away from the family and find a mate. So sort of from that kind of evolutionary perspective, it promotes development. There's also adaptive ways that it can happen just in terms of these more positive risks that I alluded to earlier, raising your hand in class, or asking your crush out on a date, or trying out for a challenging sports activity or something else that might be challenging that you might be scared to do, but
冒险可以是适应性的方式。一种是从进化的角度来看，走出去，从环境中学习，参与各种灵活的行为，试错有助于青少年学习、发展并探索他们是谁以及什么对他们重要。这使他们能够结交新朋友，离开家庭并寻找伴侣。所以从那种进化的角度来看，它促进了发展。还有一些适应性的方式，正如我之前提到的那些更积极的风险，在课堂上举手，或者约你喜欢的人出去约会，或者尝试一项具有挑战性的体育活动或其他可能具有挑战性、你可能害怕去做但
kind of taking the risk to try it, are all ways that risks can. be highly adaptive in adolescence. Now, you've tackled another stereotype in your research, which is that teens are more self-centered than adults. That's a pretty common idea. But as you've pointed out, there's a countervailing stereotype that many teens are driven to change the world for the better. I mean, a lot of the big social movements of our time from climate change to Black Lives
冒着风险去尝试的事情，这些都是风险在青春期具有高度适应性的方式。现在，您在研究中解决了另一个刻板印象，即青少年比成年人更以自我为中心。这是一个非常普遍的观点。但正如您所指出的，存在一种相反的刻板印象，即许多青少年有动力去改变世界，使其变得更美好。我的意思是，我们这个时代许多重大的社会运动，从气候变化到“黑人的命也是命”
Matter have been led in part by adolescents. So how do these ideas fit together? Are teens more self-centered than adults? or are they more idealistic and driven to do more good in the world? Adolescence, I think, is just such a remarkable developmental period. So for all of the reasons that the brain is developing and changing and thought to be negative are many of the reasons that adolescents are engaging in really positive behavior. So, for example, increases in the ventral stratum that I discussed earlier that is related to
运动，在一定程度上都是由青少年领导的。那么这些观点是如何结合在一起的呢？青少年比成年人更以自我为中心吗？还是他们更理想主义，更有动力去为世界做更多的好事？我认为青春期是一个非常了不起的发展阶段。因为大脑发育和变化的所有原因，以及被认为是负面的原因，很多也是青少年参与真正积极行为的原因。例如，我之前讨论过的腹侧纹状体的增加，这与
reward value and feeling good are increasing during adolescence. And at the same time, brain regions involved in social perspective taking are increasing. And these together, I think, really promote the ability of adolescents to engage in really meaningful activities that bring them joy. So that reward sensitivity while also taking the perspective of others and thinking about the broader societal needs of their community. And so we see that adolescents, as you mentioned, are engaging in really positive behaviors during this. period. They're leading social movements. They're also doing this at a smaller scale, whether that be contributing to their family or helping their friends or volunteering at their local community. Some teens do this at such a huge level. So leading the climate change movements, leading these bigger
奖励价值和感觉良好有关，在青春期正在增加。与此同时，涉及社会视角采择的大脑区域也在增加。我认为，这些共同促进了青少年参与真正有意义并给他们带来快乐的活动的能力。因此，那种奖励敏感性，同时又能采纳他人的观点并思考社区更广泛的社会需求。所以我们看到，正如您所提到的，青少年在此期间正在参与真正积极的行为。他们正在领导社会运动。他们也在小范围内这样做，无论是为家庭做出贡献、帮助朋友还是在当地社区做志愿者。一些青少年在如此巨大的层面上做到这一点。所以领导气候变化运动，领导这些更大
scale movement that have gotten tons and tons of people involved. But it doesn't have to happen at that scale and adolescents in their everyday lives are doing activities that are pro-social and community-oriented. And they're not doing this just to like get into college, for example, but there's research showing that these brain regions involved in reward sensitivity and social sensitivity are activated, suggesting that it really does bring them joy to engage in this. And it is a meaningful activity for adolescents. How does culture affect teens' experiences of adolescence? Do teens in different countries show similar changes in behavior and brain development during the years that you study?
规模的运动，让成千上万的人参与进来。但这不必发生在那个规模上，青少年在日常生活中正在进行亲社会和社区导向的活动。他们这样做不仅仅是为了进入大学，例如，但有研究表明，这些涉及奖励敏感性和社会敏感性的大脑区域被激活，这表明参与这些活动确实给他们带来了快乐。这对青少年来说是一项有意义的活动。文化如何影响青少年的青春期经历？在您研究的这些年里，不同国家的青少年在行为和大脑发育方面表现出相似的变化吗？
In a way, adolescent is a social construction. And so the society that you live in determines how adolescence is viewed. So the stereotypes of adolescents are determined by the culture we live in. In some cultures, adolescence is described as a time of risk-taking. and this storm and stress, which was one of the very original ways of describing adolescents. And some cultures don't view it in that way. And what's really interesting is that in the way that one's culture views adolescence, oftentimes adolescence is experienced in those ways.
在某种程度上，青春期是一种社会建构。因此，你所处的社会决定了青春期是如何被看待的。所以对青少年的刻板印象是由我们所处的文化决定的。在某些文化中，青春期被描述为冒险的时期，以及这种风暴和压力，这是描述青春期的最初方式之一。而有些文化并不这样看待它。非常有趣的是，在一种文化看待青春期的方式中，青春期往往是以那些方式被体验的。
So there has been cross-cultural research, for example, Young Q, who's now an assistant professor at Northwestern, has done research in China and the United States, to look at how these stereotypes of adolescents are different. And they differ in China and they differ in the United States. And China adolescents is viewed less so at this time of risk-taking in peer influence and more so as this time of family obligation and educational motivation than, for example, in the U.S. And so there's definitely ways in which the culture that we live in can affect how
因此，已经有了跨文化研究，例如现在西北大学的助理教授Young Q，他在中国和美国进行了研究，以观察这些对青少年的刻板印象有何不同。它们在中国和美国有所不同。在中国，青春期被视为冒险和同伴影响的时期较少，而更多地被视为家庭义务和教育动机的时期，例如与美国相比。所以我们所处的文化确实可以在某些方面影响
adolescents are viewed. and what's important to keep in mind is that these stereotypes and views of adolescents are often self-fulfilling prophecies. So if I grow up in a culture that views adolescence as this time of risk-taking, I'm more likely to think that adolescence is a time of risk-taking and therefore engage in more risk-taking because I think that that's what adolescents are supposed to do. And so there's definitely ways in which culture impacts just,
青少年是如何被看待的。需要记住的是，这些对青少年的刻板印象和看法往往是自我实现的预言。如果我在一种将青春期视为冒险时期的文化中长大，我更有可能认为青春期是冒险的时期，因此参与更多的冒险行为，因为我认为这就是青少年应该做的。所以文化确实在某些方面影响了
the mere experience of what adolescence is described as the stereotypes that are endorsed by that group and how adolescents growing up in that culture might view and experience adolescents themselves. What about differences between the sexes? A lot of people say that girls are more mature than boys, that they are more sensible than their male counterparts. Do girls take fewer risks? or is this a groundless belief or do they take different types of risks? Yeah, that's a great question that I don't have the full answer for. But the short answer just from our work is that we don't find gender differences. Boys and girls don't differ in the amount of risks they take.
青春期被描述的仅仅是体验，该群体所认可的刻板印象，以及在那种文化中长大的青少年自己如何看待和体验青春期。性别之间有什么差异吗？很多人说女孩比男孩更成熟，她们比男性同龄人更明智。女孩承担的风险更少吗？还是这是一个毫无根据的信念，或者她们承担不同类型的风险？是的，这是一个很好的问题，我没有完整的答案。但从我们的工作来看，简短的回答是我们没有发现性别差异。男孩和女孩在他们承担的风险数量上没有区别。
I think we need more well-powered studies. And by that, I mean large sample sizes that look at risk-taking across many different behaviors to get a better sense of whether girls and boys might. differ in the types of risks that they take. There are in the literature out there, I'm less versed with it, so don't want to say too much, but there is some evidence that girls and boys might differ in terms of externalizing behaviors, for example. But I think that girls and boys actually are more similar to each other than they are different, and that the variability is really within these groups of adolescents. So it will range across girls as much as it will range across boys.
我认为我们需要更多样本量充足的研究。我的意思是，观察许多不同行为中冒险行为的大样本量，以更好地了解女孩和男孩在他们承担的风险类型上是否可能有所不同。文献中确实存在一些证据，我对此不太熟悉，所以不想说太多，但有一些证据表明女孩和男孩在外部化行为方面可能有所不同，例如。但我认为女孩和男孩实际上比他们之间的差异更相似，而且变异性确实存在于这些青少年群体中。所以它在女孩中的范围和在男孩中的范围一样大。
Do you know whether there are differences based on race and ethnicity or socioeconomic status? You could imagine that somebody who is living in a tougher situation, you might be willing to take more risks because, you know, what do I have to lose here? Right? My life is already tough. Yes, there's definitely evidence, especially when it comes to socioeconomic status. that teens from lower SCIS environments are more likely to take risks and engage in externalizing behaviors for exactly the point you raise that, like, what is there to lose? Or actually, maybe there's something really to gain by engaging that's risk-taking. So if my family can't afford to put food on the table, I might go out and steal or engage in other
您知道是否存在基于种族、民族或社会经济地位的差异吗？你可以想象，生活在更艰难处境中的人，你可能更愿意冒险，因为，你知道，我在这里有什么可失去的呢？对吧？我的生活已经很艰难了。是的，绝对有证据，特别是在社会经济地位方面。来自较低社会经济地位环境的青少年更有可能冒险并参与外部化行为，原因正是你提出的，比如，有什么可失去的呢？或者实际上，也许通过参与冒险行为真的能获得什么。所以如果我的家庭负担不起餐桌上的食物，我可能会出去偷窃或参与其他
behaviors in order to help my family. And that's considered a huge risk, but it may actually be in the end. the outcome is helpful for them and their family, or being exposed to an environment that has lots of risks and negative experiences in the environment, whether you're growing up in a place with a lot of violence or being exposed to other things. There's instances where either taking a risk is a good thing or taking a risk is something that is socialized within that environment because of what you're exposed to. When it comes to ethnic racial differences, the
行为以帮助我的家庭。这被认为是一个巨大的风险，但最终结果对他们和他们的家庭可能有帮助，或者暴露在一个有很多风险和负面经历的环境中，无论你是在一个有很多暴力的地方长大还是暴露在其他事情中。在某些情况下，冒险是一件好事，或者冒险是因为你所暴露的环境而被社会化的一种行为。当谈到种族民族差异时，
literature is much more mixed. And so there's not kind of clear differences there. I think, again, similar to boys and girls, there's more similarities than there are differences. And the differences are not at all due to anything that's like biologically wired that's different between racial or ethnic groups, but perhaps something that is culturally socialized if there are differences that are found. In our culture, we have kind of prolonged adolescence. I mean,
文献要复杂得多。所以那里没有明确的差异。我认为，再次与男孩和女孩类似，相似之处多于差异。这些差异根本不是由于种族或民族群体之间生物学上的任何不同，而是如果发现差异，可能是文化社会化的结果。在我们的文化中，我们有某种延长的青春期。我的意思是，
you know, kids are living with their parents longer for economic and for other reasons. You know, we're really sort of, in a sense, you might say, you know, we've been coddling our kids. Is that having an impact on their desire to take risks there and risks that might be good for them? Yeah. So in either societies where kids have to grow up, up sooner or for other reasons where you might have to grow up sooner. For example, if you don't have lots of resources or parents who are available. And for example, if you're in the foster system and don't have a mom and dad necessarily to support you well past 18, you might have to grow up sooner. Whereas for teens in higher SDS environments or for those who do have parents who
你知道，孩子们因为经济和其他原因与父母住在一起的时间更长。你知道，从某种意义上说，你可能会说，你知道，我们一直在溺爱我们的孩子。这是否对他们冒险的愿望以及对他们有益的风险产生了影响？是的。所以在孩子们必须更早长大的社会中，或者因为其他原因你可能必须更早长大。例如，如果你没有很多资源或可用的父母。例如，如果你在寄养系统中，没有妈妈和爸爸在18岁以后支持你，你可能必须更早长大。而对于处于较高社会经济地位环境中的青少年，或者对于那些确实有父母可以
one can live with for longer past the high school years when you're technically defined by society to be an adult. This provides an opportunity to kind of grow up slower. In a lot of ways, this can be positive. There's research from both animal models and actually human models showing that the brain slows down in development when given the opportunity to, but speeds up and becomes more mature sooner in environments where you kind of have to grow up sooner. And both are adaptive. You're adapting to the environment to which you need to either grow up sooner or have more opportunity to explore your environment.
在高中毕业后（当你技术上被社会定义为成年人时）可以住在一起更长时间的人来说，这提供了一个变相“慢速成长”的机会。在很多方面，这可能是积极的。来自动物模型和人类模型的研究表明，当给予机会时，大脑的发育会减慢，但在必须更早长大的环境中，大脑会加速并更早变得成熟。两者都是适应性的。你正在适应你需要更早长大或有更多机会探索你的环境的环境。
And so by prolonging adolescents, we're giving teams the opportunity to explore more, explore their identity, explore different opportunities for like, who they want to be when they grow up, engage in different types of risk that might be very adaptive for reaching those goals. And so if you're in an environment that allows you to kind of slow down that process of developing and growing up, then it's perhaps a positive thing for youth and not something that we necessarily need to look down on. Like they're just not growing up and they're staying teenagers forever and they're not getting married and having kids until later. Maybe this is a positive thing that allows them to really explore and define who they are and
因此，通过延长青春期，我们给青少年提供了更多探索的机会，探索他们的身份，探索不同的机会，比如，他们长大后想成为什么样的人，参与不同类型的风险，这些风险对于实现这些目标可能非常有适应性。所以如果你处于一个允许你减慢发展和成长过程的环境中，那么这对年轻人来说可能是一件积极的事情，而不是我们必须看不起的事情。就像他们只是没有长大，他们永远是青少年，直到后来才结婚生子。也许这是一件积极的事情，让他们真正探索和定义他们是谁，并
make decisions that are going to be the best for them as they reach adulthood. Now, you also study teens and technology and social media use, and I know you're interested not only in how it's affecting their social and emotional lives, but how it might be shaping their brain development. Can you talk about that? What are the questions you're trying to answer by looking at this particular situation? Yeah, so social media has really, I think, changed the social landscape of what adolescents looks like today compared to, for example, when I was a teenager and had to see my peers either in person or talk to them on the phone in order to interact with them. There's this around-the-clock ability to, um, and
做出在他们成年时对他们最有利的决定。现在，您还研究青少年和技术以及社交媒体的使用，我知道您不仅对它如何影响他们的社交和情感生活感兴趣，还对它如何塑造他们的大脑发育感兴趣。您能谈谈吗？通过观察这种情况，您试图回答什么问题？是的，社交媒体确实，我认为，改变了今天青春期的社会景观，与例如我十几岁时相比，当时我必须亲自见到我的同伴或在电话里与他们交谈才能与他们互动。现在有一种全天候的能力，嗯，和
engage either synchronously or asynchronously. And by that, I mean, you can be texting back and forth into the wee hours of the night. You can be scrolling through social media and putting up comments and getting likes and getting feedback on that very quickly. And this, we think, has really changed what it means to be an adolescent, what peer relationships might look like, teens' ability to connect with others, their sense of loneliness. And this is happening in both good and bad ways. And so we're trying to unpack what that means in terms of how they're able to stay connected to others, to find others who might share their similar interests.
参与，无论是同步还是异步。我的意思是，你可以一直发短信到深夜。你可以滚动浏览社交媒体，发表评论，获得点赞，并非常快地得到反馈。我们认为，这确实改变了作为青少年的意义，同伴关系可能看起来是什么样子，青少年与他人联系的能力，他们的孤独感。这正在以好坏两方面发生。因此，我们正在试图解开这意味着什么，关于他们如何能够与他人保持联系，找到可能分享相似兴趣的其他人。
And ways that this may be increasing their sense of loneliness or negative aspects on their body image. The exciting piece that we're starting to explore, which we don't have data to share yet, is how this might be co-occurring with their brain development. So we know that the adolescent brain is highly sensitive to rewards. It's highly sensitive to social feedback. And so how might this interact with the ways that they're engaging in these online platforms in social media and digital media context? And does the brain then get shaped by those experiences because the brain itself is highly plastic and sensitive to its environment? The adolescent period is a huge time of brain development, second only to that that we see in infancy. And so not only do we see this heightened sensitivity in terms of reward sensitivity and social sensitivity,
以及这可能增加他们的孤独感或对身体形象产生负面影响的方式。我们开始探索的令人兴奋的部分，虽然我们还没有数据可以分享，是这如何可能与他们的大脑发育同时发生。所以我们知道青少年大脑对奖励高度敏感。它对社会反馈高度敏感。那么这如何与他们参与这些在线平台、社交媒体和数字媒体环境的方式相互作用呢？大脑是否会因为这些经历而被塑造，因为大脑本身具有高度的可塑性并对环境敏感？青春期是一个巨大的大脑发育时期，仅次于我们在婴儿期看到的发育。因此，我们不仅看到这种在奖励敏感性和社会敏感性方面的敏感性增强，
but we see that the environment and things that teens are exposed to can shape further brain development. And so we don't yet know how these digital media platforms and what they're experiencing online might be integrated into their brains. So that's something that we're just very interested in exploring and are starting to conduct longitudinal research to follow teens across time and understand the bidirectional relationships here. So how is adolescents' neurobiological sensitivity affecting maybe how they engage online and vice versa? How is the way that they engage on these digital platforms shaping potential changes in brain development across time? I thought it was really interesting.
而且我们看到环境和青少年所接触的事物可以进一步塑造大脑发育。因此，我们还不知道这些数字媒体平台以及他们在网上经历的事情如何可能被整合到他们的大脑中。所以这是我们非常有兴趣探索的事情，并且正在开始进行纵向研究，以随着时间的推移跟踪青少年并理解这里的双向关系。那么青少年的神经生物学敏感性如何影响他们在线参与的方式，反之亦然？他们在这些数字平台上参与的方式如何随着时间的推移塑造大脑发育的潜在变化？我觉得这非常有趣。
And there was a recent Forbes article about your technology research and Jim Winston, whose foundation funds the center at UNC that you had. He said, a child born today and primarily raised on devices will be neurobiologically incapable of reading war and peace as an adult, not lazy or unmotivated. Incapable. Do you agree with that? I mean, do we even know whether that's the case? I don't think we know. We definitely need empirical research that follows youth from childhood to adolescence into adulthood to be able to answer that question.
最近有一篇关于您的技术研究的《福布斯》文章，吉姆·温斯顿（他的基金会资助了您所在的北卡罗来纳大学中心）说，一个今天出生并主要在设备上长大的孩子，成年后将在神经生物学上无法阅读《战争与和平》，不是因为懒惰或缺乏动力。是无法阅读。您同意这一点吗？我的意思是，我们甚至知道情况是否如此吗？我不认为我们知道。我们绝对需要跟踪年轻人从童年到青春期再到成年期的实证研究，才能回答这个问题。
question. We really don't have the data yet to even know how their use of digital media is impacting brain development and their ability to do things like read War and Peace. And so we're just not there yet. We need much more research to be able to support those types of comments. And that's exactly what we're trying to do with our longitudinal research is to be able to understand these mechanisms and how digital media might shape brain development and of course, vice versa for both good and bad ways. We don't know the positive and negative ways that this could be occurring because like I said with the growing up too fast versus maturing more early, how that impacts brain development. It's the same thing with digital media. The brain is
问题。我们确实还没有数据来了解他们对数字媒体的使用如何影响大脑发育以及他们阅读《战争与和平》等事情的能力。所以我们还没有达到那个阶段。我们需要更多的研究来支持这些类型的评论。这正是我们试图通过纵向研究来做的事情，即能够理解这些机制以及数字媒体如何塑造大脑发育，当然反之亦然，无论是好是坏。我们不知道这可能发生的积极和消极方式，因为就像我说的关于成长太快与更早成熟一样，这如何影响大脑发育。数字媒体也是如此。大脑是
adapting to its environment. And so in a way, whatever the brain is doing to respond to, these social inputs is adaptive, whether we qualify that as a good thing or bad thing is subjective, I think. And so understanding these processes is going to take a lot of time because we need to do longitudinal research. And also we need to take into context whether this is a good thing or bad thing because much of it is subjective based on what we think adolescent should be doing or how we think these outcomes are impacting their development. Any other big questions that you're trying to answer at this point? I think that our main research is really just trying to unpack and answer a lot of the potential stereotypes that are out there.
适应其环境的。所以从某种意义上说，大脑为响应这些社会输入所做的任何事情都是适应性的，我们将其定性为好事还是坏事是主观的，我认为。因此，理解这些过程将需要很长时间，因为我们需要进行纵向研究。而且我们还需要考虑到这是否是一件好事或坏事，因为其中大部分是基于我们认为青少年应该做什么或我们认为这些结果如何影响他们的发展的客观性。目前您还在试图回答其他任何重大问题吗？我认为我们的主要研究确实只是试图解开和回答许多潜在的刻板印象。
So we have work happening right now looking at peer influence. So we talked about this earlier, but also really considering the positive side of peer influence is one of our big. goals, there is just as much evidence suggesting that peers can push teens to engage in very good behaviors and change their attitudes in more positive ways as there is evidence on the contrary that peers drive teens to be more risky. And so this is a big area of research that we're eager to contribute to more and kind of debunk if we can with empirical evidence, this idea that teens are driving each other to engage in more negative and deviant behaviors, but actually are promoting very positive behaviors as well. Well, Dr. Telzer, this has been very interesting. I really
所以我们现在正在进行关于同伴影响的工作。所以我们之前讨论过这一点，但真正考虑同伴影响的积极方面是我们的大目标之一，有同样多的证据表明同伴可以推动青少年参与非常好的行为并以更积极的方式改变他们的态度，就像有相反的证据表明同伴驱使青少年变得更冒险一样。因此，这是一个我们渴望做出更多贡献的研究领域，如果我们能用实证证据揭穿这种认为青少年正在驱使彼此参与更多负面和越轨行为，但实际上也在促进非常积极行为的观点。好吧，泰尔泽博士，这非常有趣。我真的
appreciate you're joining me today. Thank you. Thank you very much for having me. You can read more about Dr. Telzer's research and other research on the teenage brain in the July-August issue of APA's magazine Monitor on Psychology. You'll find a link on our website at www. www. speakingof psychology.org. You can also find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology there or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you hear, please leave us a review.
感谢您今天加入我。谢谢。非常感谢您的邀请。您可以在美国心理学会杂志《心理学监测》7月-8月刊上阅读更多关于泰尔泽博士的研究以及关于青少年大脑的其他研究。您可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 上找到链接。您也可以在那里或在 Apple、Stitcher 或您获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果您喜欢您所听到的，请给我们留下评论。
If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condiyan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果您对未来的播客有意见或想法，您可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪扬。感谢您的收听。代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。